hi welcome to science hangout from
science mission today we have dr. Mike
close associate professor in the
Department of Chemistry and biochemistry
from the University of Oregon is with us
dr. cliff has won several awards in 2016
in d1 University of Oregon outstanding
award in 2016 a dmg one community F is
featured scholar award in 2015
I'm chemistry journal award again in
2015
Alfred Sloan fellowship in 2015 he won
and the noir NSF Career Award and 2010
NIH pathway to independence about in
addition he also has won several awards
during his the first doctor tenure as
well as - welcome dr. blood hi thanks
for having me so thanks for joining us
absolutely can you please tell us about
yourself absolutely so I'm a native
Oregonian and was a chemistry and math
major at the University of Oregon as an
undergraduate student and then went to
graduate school at the University of
California Berkeley where I really
became interested in in mechanistic
chemistry and trying to understand how
you can engineer molecules to carry out
specific purposes that you want and
during that time I I became a somewhat
more interested in biological chemistry
and so moved to MIT as a postdoc where I
worked on developing chemical tools who
are looking at small molecules in
different biological systems and then I
started my independent career in 2011
at the University of Oregon where I've
been developing chemical tools for
looking and other small molecules in in
biology mainly ones that evolved around
sulfur so like you have a pretty good
very nice video
and can you please tell us about some of
your mentors or the role models who
supported you during your that yeah sure
so I've always been very fortunate to
have very good mentors even starting as
an undergraduate where I started as a
researcher in the lab having very
supportive mentors who really fostered
curiosity and and made me want to think
about you know big picture ideas and not
just the small things I could do every
day but but how these could relate to
your questions and then as a graduate
student had the very interesting
experience of having two PhD advisers
and the thing that I found very
interesting about that is they
approached problems from very different
perspectives but almost always came to
the same answer I found that really
really interesting and educational
because initially that that there's not
one right way to do things and not one
right way to think about prager to that
really understanding the the core issues
involved really leads you I kind of down
the path of discovery and so thinking
having people who have fostered
creativity and been great mentors and
great teachers throughout my educational
career has been very important and very
fun for me too I think is a big big part
of it so you know you can tell you I
know you think if you look and uh like I
said what so you go other things that
hobbies and interests other memory says
yeah so I really like photography and
traveling those often go hand-in-hand so
I'd like to take pictures of different
things I also quite like gardening so a
lot of faculty friends have have gardens
as well and we kind of compare notes in
and so you can grow the biggest best
tomato sometimes I think that's always a
good dispatcher
and let's talk about your lab and lab
people so can you please describe your
lab sure none of the postdocs
yesterday yeah so right right now my lab
has one postdoctoral researcher three
undergraduates and seven undergraduates
and so we just a number of graduate
students graduate which is great and
they have jobs just fantastic and kind
of the the general standards feet
personnel account for my lab is probably
one to two postdocs and six to eight
graduate students and then about the
same number of undergraduate so for me I
think it's really important to have a
mixture of researchers at those
different career levels because most
people who are in graduate school or who
are postdocs got their their start and
inspiration in in research as an
undergraduate so I think providing that
opportunity for current undergraduates
is very important to help foster have
the next generation of scientists and I
think it's also good for for graduate
students to have experience in training
younger scientists and postdocs having
the experience in training graduate
students and undergraduates as well and
how do you motivate them like it's the
kill you end up dead like so like
sometimes that he said that he said this
kind of up and down you don't get that I
think that every time that's right
that's right so one one thing that I I
tell almost every undergraduate who
joins my lab is that in laboratory
classes as an undergraduate all of the
experiments are engineered to work 95%
of the time and if you follow directions
you'll get the reaction to work almost
all the time whereas in a research it
turns out in my experience at least that
about 95 of the reactions you run don't
work and so that's a very different
experience and you really have to kind
of grow tenacious and and and understand
that just because things don't give you
the result that you are expecting or
that don't work exactly how they might
if you can learn something from that
experiment even if it's an experimental
technique or a new way to think about
analysis tells us a successful
experiment so I think that that really
trying to motivate students to expand
their toolbox and develop a greater
selection of tools that they can use to
look at current and future problems is a
good way to to motivate them and help
Wendy did I say everyday eh yeah yeah so
I mean I I think most people in my lab
would would tell you the same thing that
you know I often walk through the lab
multiple times each day and stop and
chat with people about the experiments
that they're doing or new results that
that they might might have and you know
I'll come and find me in my office also
I think that one thing that's very
interesting is is in scientific training
as an undergraduate graduate student and
a postdoc you're in the lab doing the
science but then as a faculty member
when you are directing research you
aren't really doing much of the actual
experiments anymore and so it's it's fun
to kind of live vicariously through the
students sometimes in terms of
experiments that they're they're doing
and coming back to that except one thank
bunk
Luka interested in hydrogen sulfide and
yeah great great question so certainly
yeah ten years ago if if you told me
that I was going to be interested in
hydrogen sulfide and worked with a lot
of sulphur containing molecules I
probably wouldn't have believed you but
when I was a postdoc at MIT I worked
with another small gaseous biologically
important molecule nitric oxide or an O
and that that really got me interested
in trying to understand how these small
being active biomolecules play important
roles in chemistry and in biology and
really that that interface was very
interesting to me and when I was a
postdoc there is a lot of new literature
coming out on hydrogen sulfide that it
might be kind of the next important
small molecule
that's involved in chemical biology so
as a graduate student I had a lot of
training in in mechanistic chemistry and
physical organic chemistry which to me
means trying to use mechanisms of
chemical reactivity to get molecules to
do things that you want them to do and
so I viewed that with my skill set I
could make an impact looking at this new
important bio molecule by by kind of
carving out a niche at the interface of
chemistry and biology using some of the
key skills that I used and learned as a
graduate student but applying them in a
new area of chemical biology so let's
say you think you a work on the self but
that but containing molecules all right
sounds good share the screen here
alright can you see that not yet yes
yeah perfect perfect great so what I'm
going to talk about is is really kind of
some of these central rules of sulphur
in biology and at the interface of
chemistry and biology which is what I am
interested in so if you want to get an
idea of recent things that come out from
my group we have a website down here
that is updated frequently and also a
Twitter feed that comes out with with
new papers and things like that from our
lab and so if we if we think about
sulphur most of us have experienced
sulphur before right so if we've ever
been to a hot spring or a geothermal
event or you know you often have this
this kind of nice haze that has this
somewhat sulfur odor that's mainly a
mixture of sulfur dioxide so so2 and
small amounts of hydrogen sulfide h2s
and if we look around here we can see a
few characteristics here we see that
there's a little bit of yellow color on
the ground that's actually elemental
sulfur if that's deposited on the ground
we also see that not a whole lot of
vegetation is living around
this hot spring because it turns out
that a lot of these sulfur molecules are
very caustic and make it hard for
different organisms to live there if
they're in behind concentrations and if
we think about the roles that sulfur
might have in biology if we look at a
periodic table and we think about
elements that are involved in life we
often think about organic chemistry
which is the chemistry of of carbon
containing molecules of carbon nitrogen
oxygen and hydrogen but we can really
expand the elements that that nature
uses if you look at the bio in organic
chemistry so now including non
carbon-based molecules we now have
things like metals so first row metals
like manganese iron cobalt copper and
zinc these are often found in lots of
different enzymes we have other alkali
metals like sodium potassium magnesium
calcium that are involved in signaling
or in bones in the case of calcium we
also have phosphorus sulfur and selenium
and these are also important bio
molecule constituents but really what
I'm going to focus on today is sulfur
and sulfur is actually the seventh most
abundant element in the human body and
so it really plays a lot of important
roles in biology and if we look at how
sulfur is involved in kind of the global
cycle it's really involved in a lot of
different things and so there's a lot of
sulfur in the Earth's crust for example
it's a lot of different ores that we'd
be mine or fossil fuels humans convert a
lot of that sulfur in the ground into
sulfur dioxide through combustion or
through different industry processes and
then in the atmosphere you get sulfates
these actually contribute to acid rain
which isn't always the best thing
this can get into the water so we have
things like sulfates in the water and
there are microbes in the water that
will convert sulfate in
two different forms of sulphur that make
it into the sediment that find other
micro organisms and then this can be
taken up by plants so there really is a
global sulfur cycle that has a lot of
different forms of sulfur in it and in
leas we can see one place where h2s is
abundant and that's actually from
volcanoes and it turns out that h2s and
other sulfide containing species are
commonly found near hot springs
volcanoes and places like that if you
look at a common sulfur containing
biomolecules one of the amino acid
cysteine has a SH group on it this is a
very important amino acid it's involved
in lots of enzymes because we can have
this SH group function as a very good
nucleophile so there's an enzyme that
carries up a reaction often that may
contain a cysteine also this can be
oxidized to form a disulfide
so these disulfides are very important
for enzyme structure or in hair it gives
it some of the be curly Michigan and
hair also have things like homocysteine
or glutathione which is a small tribe
peptide this is the primary file in a
lot of living systems and it's really
important in the redox balance so if we
think about an antioxidant glutathione
is is major boost abundant file
containing antioxidant and then we also
have things like Mathon amine which is
an essential you know acid meaning that
we have to eat this we can't make it
ourselves and this is also found in
s-adenosylmethionine which is an
important enzyme cofactor for lots of
different reactions and one thing that I
really think makes first special and
makes or at least contributes to why
it's so important in biology is that
it's really complicated we may think of
that as a bad thing but the fact that
it's complicated means that it can
actually have a lot of different
oxidation states meaning that it can
either have or be missing a lot of
and that is really important because a
lot of reactions in biology involve
electron transfer so transporting
electrons from one molecule to another
maybe from an enzyme to a substrate it's
the fact that sulfur can access so many
different oxidation states makes it very
versatile and if we think about hydrogen
sulfide h2s this is actually a weak acid
so it exists both as h2s and as an anion
a mono anion hydrosulfide we also have a
lot of different sulphur containing
species in biology we saw tiles before
this could be cysteine we can have
sulfenic acids which are an oxidized
form of cysteine that are important in
signaling you also have nitros those
files these are important in the
crosstalk between files and nitric oxide
another important small gaseous molecule
we have other oxidized forms of sulfur
like a personified the strange SS h
functional group we have polysulfides
these are chains of sulfur atoms linked
together these can range anywhere from
three or two or three solvers to much
longer chains we have other oxidized
forms of sulfur like self oxides
elemental sulfur or species with sulfur
and oxygen in them and there are
bacteria that can essentially convert
sulfur all the way from its reduced
state to its fully oxidized state and
back the other direction which
essentially gives a lot of of organisms
the ability to create or use energy and
as I mentioned before and much of my lab
is interested in hydrogen sulfide so
let's talk a little bit about some basic
properties if you look for images of
hydrogen sulfide you'll often find a lot
of these caution h2s signs it turns out
that at high concentrations hydrogen
sulfide is quite toxic I'm almost sure
that everyone has smelled I didn't
sulfide at some point in their lives
it's the classic rotten egg smell you
have you smelled that before it's it's
hydrogen sulfide in water it's a weak
acid which
actually quite it was a very important
property because HTTPS itself can be
deprotonated to form hydrosulfide
anion he's a very very water soluble
because more hydrophobic h2s form can
easily cross cell membranes is very
important in different biological
systems and it turns out that if you
look at the chemistry of hydrogen
sulfide a lot of the chemistry has been
well developed in geochemistry for a
long time because a lot of very colorful
minerals are metal sulphide salts so
cinnabar is a red mineral it's mercury
sulphide fool's gold or pyrite is iron
sulfide zinc sulfide is very nice blue
color so it's really a lot of
geochemistry that's involved in in
sulfide as well but I've mentioned that
h2s and hydrogen sulfide are very
important in life and if we look to at
the history of evolution on earth we
might get some clues as to why that is
and so if we look at the levels of
hydrogen sulfide shown in green here
throughout history about 3.8 million
years ago where the first micro fossils
were found at that point there were
median the levels of hydrogen sulfide
really no oxygen left but a lot of iron
and then there was a great mountain
station event which is thought to be the
formation of oxygen by cyanobacteria
and what happened here is we now have a
lot of oxygen that is is is being formed
and this can interact with the iron and
the sulfur that's around actually
increased the amount of free hydrogen
sulfide in in the oceans and so during
this time organisms were evolving in the
presence of really large concentrations
of hydrogen sulfide and then as oxygen
concentrations go up Oh to will turns
out to oxidize a lot of this hydrogen
sulfide back down to sulfate and
polysulfides and modern animals part
four but really for about you know
almost a billion years there was a lot
of interplay between evolution iron and
hydrogen sulfide you
this formed a lot of really important
iron sulfur centers which are still
found in almost all living organisms
today and a great way to transport
electrons in different systems and if we
think back to the toxicity of hydrogen
sulfide it's just kind of a basic chart
showing some of the toxicity it's
actually one of the compounds that that
the human nose is the most sensitive to
so we can detect hydrogen sulfide and
identify it about 500 parts per million
and this is probably an evolutionary
mechanism because h2s is often given off
from from bacteria that live in
anaerobic or oxygen deficient
environments so maybe if you had a food
supply that was not very safe it might
have hydrogen sulfide so it makes sense
that we can detect this at quite low
levels as you get up into higher
concentrations of parts per million at
levels we get eye irritation you start
to get tissue damage and if you get over
about a thousand parts per million that
can result in death but at much lower
concentrations hydrogen sulfide is
actually a very important biomolecule
and joins other gases nitric oxide and
carbon monoxide as what are called
gayssot transmitters so these are
molecules that are small gases that are
produced by an organism and serve a
physiological function within the same
organism and so of these three molecules
hydrogen sulfide is certainly the most
recent to be added to this group and
that's kind of why we became interested
in h2s because it's an area where I
think chemists biologists and
physiologists can really look at
important problems and look at them from
different perspectives and so looking at
kind of a history of h2s here it's
thought that about 250 million years ago
a large acidification in oceans resulted
in the release of h2s from much of the
water on earth killing about 95 percent
of terrestrial life one of the first
examples that I could find relating to
each to us in the Gulf of
was in 1713 of the early 1700 s when he
was shown that that in London sewer
workers who complained of ie irritation
often had black coins in their pockets
and at the time coins are made of copper
we now know that's copper sulphide which
is very dark color so it makes sense
that that workers who are exposed to
high levels of chronic hydrogen sulfide
had some physiological impacts of them
and then moving forward quite a bit here
what really got me interested in
hydrogen sulfide was when I was a
graduate student I wasn't actually
working on chemistry related to h2s but
there is a very interesting paper that
showed that if you took an animal like a
mouse and exposed it to about 80 to 100
parts per million of hydrogen sulfide in
the absence of oxygen that the mouse
didn't die but rather than Mouse would
go into a suspended animation like state
where its pulse and breathing would slow
down quite a bit and its core
temperature would also drop you could
email in that state for a number of
hours remove all the hydrogen sulfide
foot oxygen back in and the mouse would
wake up and and not have any long-term
damage so I think that convinced a lot
of people that that H to us is really an
important biomolecule it's doing a lot
of interesting chemistry in living
systems that is worth figuring out and
so if we think about where - sulfide
comes from as we look a fairly
complicated really the key point here is
that there are a number of enzymes that
can transfer the Thyle s h group from
things like homocysteine which we saw
earlier or a cysteine and make hydrogen
sulfide and these enzymes are
distributed widely throughout the body
there their distribution is somewhat
tissue specific meaning that there may
be different ways to activate these
different types of enzymes
systems if you talk about some of the
roles of hydrogen sulfide in the human
body it's really quite important in a
lot of different organ systems its
includes the cardiovascular system the
lungs the brain in the GI tract and
really almost every day there are new
papers coming out showing new roles of
hydrogen sulfide in different organ
systems a few examples that I think are
kind of interesting so in one of an
early example of a mouse model that is
missing one of the key h2s producing
enzymes that means if it's missing one
of these enzymes does not produce as
much hydrogen sulfide as you would
normally expect this has shown that the
tissues in the heart of the mice that
are missing this enzyme do produce less
hydrogen sulfide than in a normal Mouse
that makes sense also things that are
quite interesting here is that the blood
pressure is somewhat modulated by
hydrogen sulfide and so as the hydrogen
sulfide is increase if you add hydrogen
sulfide to these mice it results in a
decrease in the blood pressure of the
mice and the mice that are missing this
key h2s producing enzyme are much more
sensitive to this suggesting that h2s
plays an important role in employment
pressure mediation and then looking at
resting blood pressure other ways we can
see that the mice missing key h2s
crusing enzymes have a much higher blood
pressure than normal mice again
consistent with roles of hydrogen
sulfide in blood pressure mediation a
few other examples that I think nicely
highlight the diverse rules that
hydrogen sulfide can play this here is
in wound healing so if you look at the
ability of mice to heal wounds these are
again comparing the animals that are
missing one of the key h2s producing
enzymes in black here versus the white
squares are the normal mice and this
here is the wound size and if we look at
a normal
feels a wound at a certain rate and
these h2s deficient mice heal the wound
much more slowly suggesting that h2s who
may play important roles in wound
healing h2s is also very important in
the gastrointestinal system and one type
of common drugs that are used are
incensed and non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs these are common
over-the-counter pain killers but these
actually can do a lot of GI damage and
in in a model here showing the gastric
damage score we see an increasing amount
of gastric damage as we increase the
amount of an NSAID that a mouse is given
Cory if the NSAID now has an H to us
releasing molecule appended to it we see
much decreased damage score suggesting
that h2s may play beneficial roles in
protecting the GI tract from damage and
then one final example here is in a
model of kidney transplant and one huge
problem in in the US and around the
world is the viability of organs for for
transplant
and often transporting them he causes
organs to no longer be viable for a
recipient and so in this model us is a
kidney transplant model in mice my
kidney is taken out from the mouse and
then stored for a while and put back in
the same mouse and we can see that not a
lot of mice survive this so after five
days almost all of the mice have died
whereas if the organs are treated with
hydrogen sulfide you see a large
increase in survival for iman's and so I
think that these three examples really
highlights the diverse roles that
hydrogen sulfide can play in different
pharmacology Xand and possibly as
therapeutic tools so what my lab is
interested in is really using chemistry
as a tool to investigate hydrogen
sulfide in biology and so things that we
are interested in we're interested in
developing new chemical tools for
detecting quantifying and imaging
hydrogen sulfide in different biological
context and so if
you want to see where you need some way
to image that or detective we're also
interested in developing compounds that
can be programmed to release
- sulfide on demand so give us a way to
deliver h2s to a certain part of an
organism and then if hydrogen sulfide is
important in biology it must be doing
some chemistry somewhere and so they
work on model of compounds to try to
understand the chemistry that's going on
with - sulfide so let's just tell you a
few snippets of things that we've been
working on in in my lab and the first of
which will focus on developing chemical
or imaging h2s in different biological
environments and one of the common tools
that scientists use to look at molecules
in live systems is fluorescence
microscopy and so these are molecules
that will you to release hydrogen light
in the presence of living any light that
are are looking for and so this is very
a very common technique and so we've
been trying to develop chemical tools
that can image h2s by fluorescence
microscopy and so ideal properties you
want imaging agents that are
water-soluble non-toxic selective for
h2s over other things that might be
around so I often describe this as
you're trying to pick out one specific
type of molecule in a waste bottle there
are many types of reactive molecules
around which are only looking for one we
also want molecules that become
fluorescents or initially dark and then
become emissive when they find the
analyte that you're looking for so this
is an illustration showing why we want a
turn-on for some probe so on the top
here if we had all the probe turned on
or emitting light I've actually
extinguished a lot of the lights in this
picture but you can't see where they are
because there are so many lights being
shown whereas down here it's the darker
background it's very clear to see that
these lights have been turned on which
if this worry was a probe would tell you
that H to us is being produced in this
environment and so we are a chemist by
training and so really we tried to use
the innate chemical properties of h2s to
develop different tools for imaging
hydrogen sulfide and so really how we've
done this is by making small molecules
that have a reactive group that can
react selectively with hydrogen sulfide
to undergo a chemical reaction and this
chemical reaction can be translated into
light and so what this is showing here
is that upon addition of hydrogen
sulfide this is is a measurement of the
light output or fluorescence of this
probe and as we add hydrogen sulfide we
see an increase in fluorescence meaning
that this compound is becoming
fluorescent when it reacts with hydrogen
sulfide and we've developed a lot of
different types of fluorescent probes
for hydrogen sulfide detection we've
made compounds that are chemi
luminescent and one benefit of these
types of molecules is that they do not
require excitation or a light source to
emit light but they just glow on their
own so these can find hundreds well five
essentially glow h2s is around we've
developed very very bright probes for
hydrogen sulfide that can be used in in
zebrafish to look at h2s production
which we'll talk about here in just a
minute we've also developed a very
versatile ways to attach these sensors
to different parts of a cell so if you
wanted to look at what was happening in
one sub cellular location we could use
this technology to to deliver these
probes to one part of the cell I've also
done studies to understand how these
sensors work so if we're going to use
outcomes of this sensor technology to
understand biological outcomes we
probably want to know how organic
chemists so we make molecules the exact
ways in which we make them are not
completely important for this context
but we really take ideas and reactions
and try to engineer them into developing
molecules that we want to use so all
this is showing is here we
make this sensor this is based on a very
bright chromophore that can emit like if
this is I group or n3 group is here this
molecule does not fluoresce once it
reacts with hydrogen sulfide it becomes
fluorescent use this as a reporter for
hydrogen sulfide
but things we need to worry about are
really there are a lot of other Thyle
containing or SH containing species or
reactive species in general in a
biological sample so we've talked about
things like cysteine or homocysteine or
glutathione other reactive small
molecules as well so we really need to
make sure that these probes we develop
are selective for the one analyte
hydrogen sulfide that were interested in
not other molecules and so what we do
commonly is we will test our fluorescent
probes against hydrogen sulfide then
also against other reactive sulphur
oxygen and nitrogen species and this
here is what we want to see we have a
large fluorescent turn-on or hydrogen
sulfide but really no turn-on for other
reactive species and so once we have
probes that work very well we'd like to
not increase their applications and try
to use them not just in a cuvette or a
test tube but actually in a biological
context so as an example of this we
collaborated with regular northeast labs
here at the University of Oregon
he's a biophysicist and what they are
interested in looking at is is using 3d
imaging techniques to look at the gut or
the the GI tract of the larval zebrafish
to give you an idea of scale this is a
five-day post fertilization and
zebrafish it's about three millimeters
in length and so what they can do is
introduce a payload which can contain
anything you want in our case the h-2a
sensor into the gut of this zebrafish
and then if we add this molecule which
I'm guessing almost everyone in the
audience has actually consumed at some
point this molecule is dye Allen
disulfide it is a main sulphur component
in garlic it reacts with files like
glutathione to give off - sulfide so if
we introduce the sensor
and this h2s donor into the gut of
zebrafish you can see a large increase
in fluorescence we're looking at the
fluorescence in the ammo box area here
in this zebrafish showing that we can
detect the h2s relief from these
compounds inside the gut of the
zebrafish and so I mentioned that this
is a common sulfur containing molecule
that is common in many things that we
eat and this has a poly sulfide in it
here's a try sulfide with three sulfur
molecules and nature actually uses this
similar motif in lots of different
molecules so we saw this this molecule
before and dial trisulfide founding
garlic and onions some of these
polysulfides are found in things like
asparagus and mushrooms and they're
really much more exotic polysulfides as
well so the key thing I'm showing here
is really a large diversity and sulfur
containing molecules in a lot of
different natural products that can be
isolated from different organisms and so
that's kind of highlighted here common
things like mushrooms onions garlic
cacti cruciferous plants often have
these sulfur containing species in them
which all release
- sulfide and so in terms of releasing
hydrogen sulfide we've actually been
interested in developing new classes of
hydrogen sulfide donors and so again
this slide the structures are not
important but just showing that there's
a large diversity of structures that
have been developed for releasing
hydrogen sulfide and key things here's a
lot of these h2s donor molecules have
either polysulfides or others sulfur
containing species that can be activated
to release hydrogen sulfide so really
what we've been interested in is
developing new ways to be able to
trigger the release of hydrogen sulfide
and to do that we've actually started
looking at another sulfur containing
carbon disulfide so we've all heard of
carbon monoxide it's like carbon dioxide
that one oxygen has been replaced with a
sulfur in carbon disulfide is actually
the most prevalent sulphur containing
gas in the atmosphere it's also been
implicated in origin of life type
chemistry because carbon disulfide is
produced by volcanoes and hot springs
and has been shown to actually
facilitate coupling peptide bonds given
an amino acid and have carbon disulfide
nearby that can facilitate forming a new
peptide bond so but when were interested
in carbonyl sulfide is there's an enzyme
called carbonic anhydrase which is
expressed essentially every living
organism its main purpose is to detoxify
curved co2 in the body and it does that
so well and is so efficient it doesn't
care if you replace one oxygen on a co2
with a sulfur into a convert carbonyl
sulfide into hydrogen sulfide and so
we've developed new ways to harness
molecules that can release carbonyl
sulfide as a new way to deliver h2s on
demand and the way that we did this what
was really trying to we engineer
well-developed chemistry that's been
developed in the medicinal chemistry
field as a way to deliver drug and so
how this works is that here labeled as
FL is a payload that we might want to
deliver and there's essentially a large
protecting group that that masks this
payload and so people have figured out
how to activate this protecting group to
undergo a cascade reaction decomp and
decompose and release this payload that
you might want and also give up
byproducts which typically people don't
really care about but our thought was
well why don't we change one of these
oxygens into a sulfur and if we did that
this would no longer release carbon
dioxide or co2 but would rather release
carbonyl sulfide or cos
and so the design here was that first
off we thought we could use this in
sensing where we could have some sort of
molecule that could react with hydrogen
sulfide he activated deliver the poly
and regenerate h2s first by forming
carbon eel sulfur but really this
technology is very versatile because it
allows us a way to engineer new ways to
release this carbonyl sulfide which then
gets converted into h2s on-demand and as
a few quick examples of this we actually
took carbonyl sulfide and treated
carbonic anhydrase with enzyme directly
with carbon disulfide we can detect h2s
being produced these enzymes are quite
efficiently making h2s we can also
inhibit the enzyme with an inhibitor and
reduce the rate of
HSUS production and this doesn't just
work in a test tube it also works in
live cells it's what we've done here is
incubated cells with one of our h2s
responsible fluorescent probes and then
introduced carbonyl sulfide and the
fluorescence increases in the cells
showing that the carbonic anhydrase in
the cells is efficient so to generate
h2s and activate the program so as one
quick example of how this can be useful
one of the primary roles of hydrogen
sulfide it was thought to be protection
against oxidative stress and so what we
did is we developed donor molecules that
have a caged molecule of carbonyl
sulfide which will convert into hydrogen
sulfide after activation but also a
triggering group that is stable until it
finds reactive oxygen species so we know
that free radicals are often damaging so
this would find free radicals be
activated and release h2s which could
then provide protection against those
free radical species and as a proof of
concept this works quite well so we can
treat these donors with hydrogen
peroxide
let's get reactive oxygen species and
see an increase in h2s being released as
we
the amount of hydrogen peroxide being
added we can also look in more detail at
what reactive species are are generating
the h2s from these donors and it's
mainly hydrogen peroxide superoxide and
proxy nitrite all of which are actually
commonly involved in immune response so
in immune cells think they're under
attack
they often pump out large amounts of
reactive oxygen species as a way of
fighting that invading pathogen and as
an example of converting this basic
chemistry from a test tube into i've
cells we can take cells here as blue
stain is just showing where the nucleus
is of each cell and shows that they're
alive if we incubate these cells with an
h2s reporter that we developed in our
lab since this molecule will be not
fluorescent in the absence of h2s but
become fluorescent when it finds h2s and
also this reactive oxygen species doing
so in the absence of reactive oxygen
species you don't activate the donor so
we don't make any age to us we don't see
any fluorescence from our probe if we
add hydrogen peroxide however that
activates the donor to release hydrogen
sulfide which is detected by our probe
and we see a large increase in
fluorescence and so this is in a system
where we add hydrogen peroxide we can
also use a different cell lines these
are immune cells and we can stimulate
these cells to think that they're under
immune attack and reliefs reactive
oxygen species
so prior to such activation we don't see
any hydrogen sulfide
but once we stimulate these cells to
produce reactive oxygen species that
activates the probe and we detect that
with our and we're really excited about
this we can actually impart protection
on cells against oxidative stress and so
this is what this graph is showing is
cell viability so how many cells are
surviving as we increase the amount of
hydrogen peroxide being added to these
cells
we know that hydrogen peroxide is a
reactive oxygen species it's by toxic
decrease in the amount of viable cells
at about a hundred micro molar I only
have about 30 percent of the cells still
alive however if we think you bait these
cells now with our donor that will be
activated by the peroxide and the liver
h2s you see a dose-dependent
increase in cell viability showing that
these donors are able to protect the
cells against the oxidative stress that
the peroxide introduces and then using
control compounds we can show that we
don't see a large increase in cell
viability if we have a molecule that
lacks the sulfur or that lacks the
reactive oxygen species triggering so
you can confirm that this this cellular
protection is due to the release of
carbon disulfide and hydrogen sulfide
from these donor molecules and it was
kind of neat because this this paper
actually got quite a bit of publicity
outside of the scientific community and
so this is picked up by a number of new
sources largely with the idea that we've
developed a new type of scaffold that
can sense oxidative stress so things
that are usually cytotoxic or damaging
and then provide protection for those
cells so we're trying to expand this
from basic cell culture models into more
complicated cell culture models and also
into animal studies so as an overview of
what we do in my lab we do a lot of
different types of chemistry so we're
really an interdisciplinary group we do
some analytical chemistry so I talked
about that with our detection method so
making fluorescent probes for - sulfide
detection we also are interested in bio
inorganic chemistry so understanding the
basic chemistry that's occurring when
hydrogen sulfide is being released and
also chemical biologists so developing
donor molecules that can influence an
impact the innate biology that's
occurring when h2s
is around really all these things
combine to inform in context and so our
goal is to take chemistry that occurs in
a test to engineer that to have an
important biological purpose and then
use that in cell culture and model
organisms to really understand what
hydrogen sulfide is doing and hopefully
make tools that kind of have some sort
of automata term pharmacological
potential and I've really had a
fantastic group of students in my lab
who do all the work so we have a
combination of graduate students and
postdocs and undergraduates
you've been very fortunate to have
funding from a number of agencies
including NIH NSF and then also private
organizations as as well and so again
you know I'd really like to thank you
for the opportunity to hear what we do
and happy to answer any sort of
questions might have on things that the
thank you dr. Brooke so can me does that
get away from the slides okay thank you
really really interesting talk a little
later I have well done this item
densified and all those things and you
are today but like learning more about
what are the things he's going to
identify I had some few questions about
some of the things the first question
would be the first slide I guess like
you showed that
fumes of by rodents Empire and other
self-replicating things education around
that but if you see the front side there
is some vegetation as you find that I
doesn't move it is not much of a few
people how does it go yes so so great
question so the question is essentially
how how do things live near these high
sulfide environments so I think can
there there are two answers there one is
that you didn't see a lot of vegetation
real close in where these sulfur gases
were being released also if people are
allowed to walk that that close to that
environment like I was to take that
picture there
very high levels of these sulfur
containing molecules being released from
these these Springs and so it turns out
that the human nose is very very
sensitive to these molecules and so we
can detect them at much lower levels
before they're toxic but also organisms
that live in those environments are well
adapted to withstand higher sulfur
content so for example in mangrove
swamps so these are are kind of the
murky waters near mangroves a lot of the
clams and other organisms that live in
that environment that often has a really
high sulfide level things that would be
quite toxic to us those organisms have
developed defense mechanisms or evolved
that their enzymes are not deactivated
by this high level of sulfide so
certainly that there are there are
organisms that can live in those
environments but they're often very
adaptable and one of the decision would
be like you showed some of the work in
the cell line
so using these identify donors and all
so have they been used in the animal
models or anything like that
yeah so we we haven't done much animal
work from our lab all the animal work
that we've done has been through
collaboration but certainly there have
been many studies out there showing the
the potentially beneficial effects of
hydrogen sulfide or hydrogen sulfide
donors especially in in situations where
there's ischemia so loss of blood flow
to Oregon or or a limb or tissue and
it's thought that hydrogen sulfide can
really provide protection against a lot
of these reactive oxygen species that
proliferate in these types of
environments so certainly there's a lot
of nice basic research and applied
research going on in these contexts to
really understand what sulfide and other
sulphur containing molecules are doing
and how that can be leveraged to
hopefully develop compounds that have
some sort of therapeutic use and one mod
aspect of this
sulphide is like you had mentioned about
onion supply leaks and all dignity yeah
multiple sulfide molecules and all those
things so like be it like cumin seeds
are onions garlic and all like and I've
heard like anecdotally that okay there
are some protective and all those things
but nobody has shown what happens inside
the body yeah basically yeah okay yeah
question would be like are these sulfide
molecules are broken down to our system
has these enzymes that can break down
the some of these multi sulfide
molecules and use them as a beneficial
effect for whatever developmental sure
so certainly people have shown that for
example garlic if you consume garlic or
in mouse models if the mouse consumes
garlic that that does increase the free
sulphide circulating levels in blood and
so certainly there is a way for that
that poly sulfide to deliver it it's h2s
and other sulfur species into the
organism certainly some of these
precursors are going to be more reactive
and probably you know will get
metabolized quite quickly but it is a
very bioavailable source of sulfur but I
think it's quite interesting and and
what one thing that I've found quite
fascinating is that a lot of the kind of
traditional medicinal uses of a lot of
plants that contain poly sulfide species
what those plants were used for before
modern medicine is often things that we
now see a beneficial effect from h2s
again so for example whether it be
reducing inflammation or or things like
that so I think that suggests that there
probably is more to the story here and
that a lot of these donor compounds or
were plants that contain these high
levels of polysulfides now may have a
way to deliver h2s to people when they
eat them
so we don't know still if any enzymes
out there that can metabolize these
polysulfides in the body or not ah you
know I I don't know so I mean I I know
that that you know the amount of
sulphide that is released and
metabolized from eating these these
things does increase the amount of salt
life I think that there still is a lot
that we can learn about those systems
okay I think that is a lot of
interesting stuff needs to be done still
so this is a really really really
interesting world and I really
appreciate you taking time and beyond
science hang out and show your work
thank you so much
look look forward to one of your great
work in the coming weeks and months and
years great all right thank thank you so
much thank you